well as far as the ukrainians are
concerned I think they have a sense of
frustration and a sense of fear and a
worry that the West hasn't really got it
and is being a bit complacent about the
situation at the moment what we see in
the last 24 hours or so here is is some
of the biggest of these kind of strikes
that we've seen the Russians launch
using missiles and drones largely at the
energy infrastructure of Ukraine and
they have plunged cities like delete Pro
a population here of a million people so
twice the population of Bristol for
instance plunged into icy Dartmouth
Center generators around me but most
people are living in very cold apartment
blocks and facing a miserable night
miserable night after night and for many
of them and it's very dangerous if
you're elderly living in these kind of
temperatures then you're looking at a
winter ahead that could claim your life
so deeply worrying for the ukrainians
and those signs no sense of a letter
from this aerial assault the Russians
are launching against these major cities
across at Ukraine I think that the fear
amongst ukrainians is that they feel
that the West is getting a sense of
complacency uh and that they feel the
ukrainians have pushed back against the
Russians in her song they pushed back
around Harkey they're putting up a
valiant defense around uh in the donbass
and I think in the west there is a sense
that there'll be a pause in the winter
and the ukrainians will continue in the
same direction uh in the year ahead and
the ukrainians have a fear that the
Russians are biting their time they are
running their troops they mobilize
hundreds of thousands of troops they now
have a new Commander a brutal but very
capable General General sirivikin whose
nickname is General Armageddon and under
his command they are planning a
counter-offensive the ukrainians
generals as we heard there in Deborah
Haynes piece that he fears that could
come in possibly to do with the
anniversary of the invasion at the end
of February so there's that fear and
there's a real frustration amongst
ukrainians that they are not getting the
weapons they need to see off this threat
frankly they should have got Patriot
missile defense systems months ago the
Americans are now signaling they are
going to get them but the ukrainians
feel they should have had it months ago
because the Russians have shown that
they are willing and capable of carrying
out these attacks on the energy
infrastructure of Ukraine and they feel
they should get more of that kind of
weapon system to see off the threat so I
think there is a sense of fear that
there's a sense of complacency building
in the west and they're warning the West
that if they don't get the weapons they
need they don't get more support and
next year could be very different to
what Generals in the west are expecting